so Carl Roes with us live in Austin Carl
good morning to you a couple things uh
little curveball here guys show us
number five first because this is
illegal
immigration um and what you're going to
see screen left is during the Trump
years and that yellow line shows you
what happened during the Biden years
okay so that that's people coming across
that's right so that's the preface for
the following sound bite with the vice
president kamla Harris and Katie
Kirk some people seem fixated on Joe
Biden's age but I want to ask you it's
cuz they have nothing to run on Katie
well immigration now they're running on
to which they could actually participate
in fixing right and so no but really you
know so yeah you're right they're
running on immigration because they like
having the problem um and they want a
political issue to run on in November
what do you think of
that I think this is complete baloney I
I I can't uh I can't remember a speech
of Kamala Harris in which he outlines a
way to cons to secure and control the
Border what does she propose when when
we've heard her talk about this she
extols the great work that she has done
in the so-called triangle working with
Guatemala Honduras and Nicaragua and
trying to strengthen their economies but
what in the heck does this
Administration think needs to be done to
secure the borders she hasn't offered a
plan all she does is she says the
Republicans haven't cooperated with us
on a plan that we haven't laid out that
doesn't make any sense so I mean this is
just politics this Administration thinks
that it's doing itself and the country
of favor by having an open door to
Illegal migration but now they're
hearing from democratic Mayors
Democratic Governors Democratic voters
in places like Chicago and Denver and
Washington DC and New York that this is
a problem well welcome to the reality of
Arizona and Texas who have been
suffering under this for a long long
time you had a reporter in Eagle Pass
that has 70,000 people in the Eagle Pass
and Del Rio sector in those two little
towns and 12,000 people a week are being
dropped off by the federal government
coming across the border and Chicago is
complaining because over the last year
and a half it's had 18,000 people
arrived try doing that every single week
and see how you like it Carl let's go on
the way way back machine remember during
the Bush Administration when uh Chuck it
was Chuck Schumer to help Obama
torpedoed the immigration bill at that
point because they said that they wanted
it as a political issue right well it
was Harry Reid but you're right it was
Democratic leader of the Senate yeah we
we we had a vote set we were setting up
a vote where we would be able to have
people a able to offer ideas and
amendments to the administration's
package a bipartisan package with John
McCain Ted Kennedy and George W bush and
we had conservatives happy with with the
idea of being able to make
recommendations to improve that package
and Harry Reid pulled that down that VOE
orama down allowed only four amendments
each one of which blew up some element
of the comprehensive immigration reform
package most of them sponsored by
Senator Byron dorgan of North Dakota
who's now who was then defeated in the
in the Senate but you're right Harry
Reid did it for one reason one reason
only he wanted to keep it alive as a
political issue so that they could say
the administration had failed to get
anything done and then Barack Obama
could do something about it when he got
elected or whomever got elected because
this was 2007 and and it was Hillary
Clinton who was at that point the front
runner but then the Democrats did
nothing about it during the time that
they were in and now we're in the fix
we're in we had the border under control
using administrative power and executive
Authority under Donald Trump now the
border is is a gigantic flood of
illegals that are taxing the social
services the law enforcement the
hospitals the neighborhoods Public
Safety all along the border and this
Administration has the terity to offer
this woman Kamala Harris who's done zero
to help secure the border and claims
that really her focus is on the the
South and Central America portion of
this you know we don't need to worry
about what's happening on the border
Carl we're out of time but I'm going to
share this look we're just back from New
Hampshire put it up guys issue number
one in New Hampshire was immigration I
mean everywhere we went in that state
everybody talked about the border now
you've got all these Republican
Governors Brian Kemp and Ron santis in
Florida Glenn yunan in Virginia they're
all like they're reaching out supporting
Governor Abbott just a quick answer on
this in our Prime Time coverage on
Tuesday night Dana came on the air and
she said if I were Donald Trump I'd go
to the Border what do you think about
that idea
now yeah absolutely but go to the border
with a concrete set of steps that need
to be taken be able to articulate what
they are and the contrast with the
lackluster do nothing policies of the
Biden Administration would be Crystal
Clear yep thank you Carl see if it
happens in Austin Carl Ro I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley airheart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis